mr spears in his court filing
wrote that he committed no wrongdoing
and his position is that as a result of
quote
engaging in no wrongdoing i think i got
his quote correct
he's entitled to in addition to the
monies that
he obtained while he was a conservator
while serving as a fiduciary
to have his daughter continue to pay him
so mr spears's issue is really twofold
one
as a matter of common sense equity and
policy
given that he is an ignominiously
suspended conservator
who has already been paid by the estate
why should he be paid anymore second
as a matter of law
where a
suspended conservator
has been involved in actual or potential
wrongdoing
under a case called xrell harris versus
shine
he should not be entitled to any legal
fees going forward
from the estate
that previously had been pillaged
this is the unusual situation where life
and law actually intertwined the law
makes sense
so to answer your question nancy
the eavesdropping issue
is front and center
as a matter of law
and because mr spears is counsel by
filing his petition opened the door put
simply
there are many categories of wrongdoing
that mr spears allegedly engaged in
the eavesdropping is one of them
and that's front and center the only
other thing i'll say on that and i don't
think i have to say much is
mr spears lawyer literally said in court
under oath
that i or my firm
somehow planted
the september 24th story
with the new york times
i'd like to think that i have that kind
of power but i actually don't that did
not happen
and yet he said that under oath
so
just going to the genesis of the
allegations and i'll take my mask off
the genesis of the allegations
are the new york times september 24th or
25th story
the september 24th documentary
i watched it
on hulu i think it was like everybody
else
and i was shocked and appalled by what i
learned
i read the story the next day
i think the judge was disappointed it's
not worth it it shouldn't be worth it to
him particularly given who his client is
here
something i take very seriously i was
deeply offended i think the court was
and it was highly inappropriate
and false obviously
i mean he told that
a few days ago does brittany want a
relationship with her i'm not going to
comment on that
what does that mean for judge penny to
rule that there's not going to be a
reserve fund it means that judge penny
ruled in the favor of my client and
ruled against mr spears so now britney's
team will have all the money from the
estate brittany is in control of her
destiny as effectively she's been since
november 12th when the conservatorship
was terminated they were in essence
trying to attach strings
mr spears it's now been publicly
disclosed
in terms of commissions and fees that he
took out of the estate that we know
about which were reported uh took about
6.3 million dollars he wants additional
monies on top of that and he wanted a
reserve to be set aside and the judge
properly rejected that request
matthew what do you think about jamie
spears wanting to unseal all records
from the conservatives
i think that that is an outrageous
request
putting aside the legal issues and why
elizabeth we believe it has no merit as
a matter of law
i ask a question that i think i
initially posed rhetorically on july
14th over there seems like years ago but
that was my first day in court
is that really what a father does
he professes
how much he loves his daughter
and yet what does he want to do now
he wants more funds from her estate
to prepare his own defense
and he wants to unseal
her private records it's contrary to law
it's contrary to common sense
and i think it's indecent do you see an
end date in sight do you feel like
there's an end do you feel like there's
an end goal well there there is there is
a major end date or was a major end date
and that was november 12th when the
conservatorship was terminated
when we signed up at brittany's request
we had two immediate goals in mind
on july 14th i announced that we were
going to move aggressively
and expeditiously
to
remove mr spears
as conservator or i should say suspend
mr spears as conservator
we filed our petition to suspend him
on july 26th
the court granted our petition and
suspended him on september 29th
and then part two of our assignment was
termination of the conservatorship and
we achieved that on november 12th those
were the two primary goals here and we
achieved both of them and i'm very proud
of that and britney is very happy about
that i was asked about the legislation i
think you asked about
as i understand it and i think this is
operative you can correct me if i'm
wrong legislation inspired by britney's
case was introduced
into the california legislature i
believe today is that correct
assembly
the assembly will substantially change
excuse me the bill will substantially
change as i understand it the probate
conservatorship system making it harder
initially for judges to establish
conservatorships in the first place
and easier for people to
get out of conservatorships the bill
also requires the court to appoint
counsel and schedule a hearing
immediately if a person wishes to
terminate their his or her
conservatorship
next the bill as i understand it also
requires conservators to consult and
make decisions aligned with the
conservatives communicated wishes which
actually
is part of the conservators handbook now
but i believe it will be codified into
law pursuant to this bill
one of the first things i learned as a
commercial litigator coming into the
space of probate law as judge penny
pointed out at the first hearing i
attended on july 14
is what a conservator is supposed to do
is act in the best interests of the
conservancy
and that's something i believe this bill
is going to address as well i think it's
fair to say that if this law had been
enacted or on the books 13 years ago
britney might not have been conserved in
the first place or there might have been
a different type of
uh lps conservatorship i believe is the
proper terminology which is a short-term
uh much more short-term short-term
conservatorship
what conservatives are also supposed to
do
what courts are supposed to do is look
at the least restrictive needs
and query whether that happens here as
well i'm not being critical of the court
but i believe that's something the
system is going to address pursuant to
this bill
so that's my take on the legislation we
think it makes sense we support it
we're proud that brittany shines a light
on some of the problems systemically as
i've said before from california to new
york and i think i've summarized the
bill and we expect it to work its way
through the legislation